ó ó
então surgiu a esta entrada
assim netanyahu eu me fez me atirar na
vida vamos falar hoje sobre a vida é uma
aventura e sobre a importância que
quando vira uma aventura que nós
encaramos de vida com uma aventura e
mesmo os rios nas próprias
não temos mãos no ar mas duas delas
serem em todas as ocasiões tendo isso a
cni as missões das coisas engraçadas uma
economista e outro que usou o tema
eletricista só as coisas também está bom
sobre sua aventura estava de partilhar
convosco algumas coisas para vocês o que
a aventura porque dão voz à tv com
descoberta é descoberta de uma coisa o
desafio
o sef a nós próprios conseguimos ter
coragem de seu mesmo ultrapassar o mesmo
fazer busca nós próprios seja o que for
na aventura há uma coisa que é comum é
que nós deve estar sempre preparados
para o que queria
isso é que a aventura hoje tivemos aqui
fantásticas rotas aventuras desde os vão
desde a joana eo nuno fizeram as provas
e maravilhosas vários anos do bicicleta
é uma falta que faz da vida uma aventura
extraordinária e eu passo aqui vou fazer
eu vou partilhar convosco grande
estardalhaço é o que é pra mim uma
aventura
não vou falar de um conjunto de coisas
que eu tenho feito nos últimos anos
explicaram que a aventura aventura para
mim r r mim próprio e fazer o que
verdadeiramente me apaixona e minha alma
não interessa o que fazemos não
interessa o contexto não ter essa
atividade
o que interessa é fazer o forma que nos
apaixona seja foi compaixão eu vou falar
sobre diversas atividades
tudo isso iniciou como falaram na área
da saúde hospitais foram os hotéis que
eu aprendi coisas simples como que a
aventura é uma mística e até os dias de
festa de aniversário de 50 anos do meu
eu dizia um luís
ventura você for não vai entrando de uma
aventura e eu próprio não lembrava que
era isso num via durante muitos anos por
isso o a apresentação falando em sua
aventura e aventura para mim forma mais
sistemática começou por volta dos 60
anos com maturidade chama espeleologia
no palavra horrível mas quer dizer
estudo das grutas produção estudo as
grutas paul giamatti da fantástica
porque nos permite em pleno século 21 e
nos locais que nunca foram pisados o
homem com muita freqüência e nós vamos
grutas e partimos certa zonas possamos
fazer uma passagem estreita e doha estão
os homens que nunca foram ultrapassados
os homens e portanto isso é uma aventura
fantástica para que pudessem pôr causa
como este que vem da fotografia em que
nós temos no rio tudo isto por professar
umas horas na terra todo molhado
entidade espera que ficava em parte uma
opção é super agradável mas é muito
agradável entre 160 e minha mãe lembra c
já passaram com facilidade assim foi o
dia que eu o caso já vai orientar alguns
anysio como essas críticas
uma outra atividade que estamos a fazer
foi escalando escalada tem uma
característica interessante é vencer o
teu próprio medo não uma forma
inconsciente e eu sou de uma época em
que estas atividades é um de aventura
não radicais ainda não virou o cacau e
sempre foram feitas enquanto você faz
com ele essa precaução vocês vêem que eu
tô cheio de material
isso é comprometida em segurança e tem
uma equipa lá atrás não está a ajudar e
da segurança quando eu me sinta tudo
isso tem que ser feito não ocorreu que
eu já vi
mexe com aventura controlado e que o
risco controlado no na minha vida a
paixão pela aventura foi sempre bem
natural ea canoagem é uma atirava
continua a funcionar aventura albufeiras
a rios e cascatas a rápidos nos permitem
fazer é fantásticas aventuras e é isso
que nós podemos fazer no dia a dia como
nos atrevemos a sair de casa e fazer
algo não precisa ser nada super
complicado você concorda que vão ter de
trabalhar montar
mas há coisas bem mais simples na qual
nós podemos fazer aventura mas existem
outros atirados nós fizemos que eu fui
fazendo ouvir outras atividades um
mergulho
o edifício quando estava na faculdade
consegue brilhar quando jogava quando
andava na faculdade e aquele triste que
entretanto o mergulho é nós temos o
mundo está tão perto esse movimento
longe vamos à praia todos vamos à praia
estamos no mar quando é que mergulhamos
e vimos o que disse para baixo pois é
que nos apercebemos que existe um mundo
completamente diferente maravilhoso que
eu acho que nós queremos fazer basta
querermos povoador e mergulhar nada
muito complicado nada muito técnicas
para fazer continuar com a idéia é
conhecer um outro mundo
o parapente o parapente é uma atirava
que o sistema já no final o lava e temos
aquele triste é ver todas as autoridades
é que ela onde uma pessoa cento mais um
erro
penso que é uma asa voando é para
aquelas embora o aspecto posso enganar o
objetivo é desculpa nem costas uir
planar e vó
nós sentimos o som do vento nas nos
planos espante se sente a paisagem para
baixo contra o nosso medo é importante
fazer isso com segurança uma história do
parapente que ficou por aqui convosco
que é uma regra para apenas que diz
assim mas valcke está com os pés em
terra de josimar avó do que estar agora
e que tem os pés em terra
isso às vezes acontece quando há muitas
turbulências muita agitação
é normal que aconteça nas outras
atividades e outras aventuras firam o
btt 81 tw hora pode ser feita em
qualquer contexto eu tive a sorte e
partilhei com o item mercado ficou nu e
se esta imagem é que me senti água e
esta era uma grande rota no algarve em
2003 com nuno teve aqui com os banners
dos robôs altas não fizemos uma
atividade fantástica com um grupo que
iria obrigar o anel foi a travessia da
estrada mais alta do mundo de btt nós
fizemos foi durante uma semana entre
duas posições que chama semanal e e
cerca de 500 quilômetros com passos
acima dos 4 metros fizemos isso
bicicleta foi uma actividade
extraordinária em termos de grupo e da
força organizada
as grandes amizades e as minhas grandes
amizades são construídas a instituição
de controle do risco e sobretudo de
aventura porque aventura também ao sonho
e essa virada foi fundamental porque nós
tínhamos chegar todos ao fim e não
interessava o que leva a melhor quem
sabe eu andava pior para manter o pacto
junto e nós conseguimos chegar como
chegamos ao i e outras coisas
vou partilhar convosco pessoal foi
pequeno em calçados cliente foi o
organismo
o mecanismo é e queremos que ele fique
dos álbuns numa das sessões que eu fiz o
salto é uma cidade fantástica tem esta
esta enquadramento das montanhas que ver
quem gosta montanha gosta de liberdade
quem gosta de verdade nossa montanha
modernismo servir nos anos 60 nos autos
nos pirinéus ou em áfrica
ontem o advogado estará em 1999 no topo
do kilimanjaro atividades fantásticas
porquê porque nós nos vamos tudo o que
luz desta prova final de que nós usamos
telemóveis computadores
nós focamos no objetivo nós concentramos
o que estamos a fazer progressos
sentimos mal nas montanhas acima se a
tal atitude e está o que chama maude
montanha que é algo que nos causa do
desconforto mal sabe mas é preciso a
gente se ver
não vai aqui muito a sério a
desvalorizar relaxar e foi o concelho
com calma e sobretudo como isa com
desvio na tanzânia pole pólo em que
entregava carinho as coisas resolvem-se
no fundo é a mensagem que estou a falar
é não muito não muito é não muito é ser
a luz faz muita competência e alguma e
alguma estrutura alguma dica são as
corridas é uma das coisas que também
nomearam que é e ver com um sistema
multi artista uma da outra no texto que
está aqui nesta sala é que o senhor está
aqui o jogo clássico porque oferece uma
nova forma
na corrida nós podemos fazer é corrigir
uma aventura é cristina barros que está
aqui está com o hospital central ontem
diferente com o amento fora de estrada
em contagens de montanha e de serra e
cinco spots fazer uma aventura vento não
tem que ser uma coisa super radical
o que eu tenho feito nos últimos anos é
um tipo de aventura diferente de alta
velocidade como poderia se casar ainda
que é super rápida nem substâncias todas
curtas e eu eo joão quase e outros
amigos que estão nessa hora fazemos um
trabalho antônio ultra maratona é uma
prova com mais 45 quilômetros somente eu
faço provas acima de 100 quilômetros
fiz há dois anos os 168 quilômetros um
treino bom é que é uma prova do mundial
e as com joão costa e fizemos este ano
também em conjunto com ele uma prova e
italia no novo mito stf fantástica mas o
triângulo variável
isto não é faz sozinha é sempre feita em
grupo você pode ver nas minhas três
filhas falando que a emissora o que move
eu queria chamar atenção sobre esses
três aspectos que estão a fazer qualquer
coisa de vida e hoje é esta sanção fosse
muito sobre aspectos importantes três
aspectos fundamentais empenho treino e
paixão sem paixão na vida tem sentido e
nada é bem feito e nada é feito
eu sei que minha vida só três pilares
minha família me amas amigo e um dos
meus mas é um pouco mais ligado
os amigos dos meus melhores amigos são
amigos que vem do tempo dos hospitais e
destas atividades de ovinhos a fazer há
50 anos ea realização pessoal e
profissional porque tudo isto nós temos
que ter paixão sem paixão nada tem senso
só que o fim de alguns anos nós temos
uma característica que eu faço isso
porque o riso sem ser partilhada é
importante em tudo que fazemos partilhar
com os outros partilhar com os amigos
fazer isto com os amigos
nós temos que são verdadeiros
isso tudo para criar para os outros
e aqui entra um complemento que é
indiferente que é tantos anos tão severa
como a que eu tenho as pessoas que
trabalham comigo com quem estou digamos
optamos por partilhar com os outros
leiria é desde há uns anos uma cidade
fantástica e tem feito coisas de
renovação vitimismo extraordinárias
eu sou a presidenta de aldo categoria e
nós orgulhamos de contribuir para que
esta cidade ou seja viva seja dinâmica e
faça um conjunto de atividades
prefeitamente inovadoras
todas as quartas feiras à noite e por
luís útil também está nessa hora que o
grande organizador deste evento
nós juntamos centenas pessoas preferem
caminhar e correndo
fizemos 83 edições já sabemos a 75 mil
pessoas se inscreveram é sair do sofá
gire fazer ao caminhar é correr não
interessa é fazer algo que tem a ver com
sente-se bem o que é o que estamos a
fazer neste momento
ontem à noite é já foi referido plano
fala nós hoje em dia estamos preocupados
numa componente algo de inclusão ou seja
uma prova ótima e boa
a casa fica isso fica a memória fica
fica alegria
estamos a fazer hoje em dia é com o
edson equipamento que só se vêem temos a
possibilidade para pessoas que têm
algumas dificuldades de mobilidade é
partilhar um bukavu esta essas
atividades que nós fazemos é algo
diferente é algo que eu acho que quem no
jogador e é algo que nós temos que fazer
mais
ontem tivemos um castelo à noite para
conseguir salvar uma salva eo paulo e
foi muito não tem graça lá porque o
castelo é giro
agora o valor castel em conjunto de
pessoas de outra forma nunca tenham
facilidade lá ir
acho que é muito mais engraçado
ia deixar vos ó mais duas ou três ideias
como é simples em ver com o seguinte é o
que o que move a mim não tem não tem que
ser o box é que dão voz sempre tem
nós encontrarmos todas as todas as
razões e as razões para conseguirmos dar
alguma forma fazer coisas que os outros
e para os outros e como diria alguém
temos que saber o que é para mim a
aventura o que comove o que é que fazem
das suas com uma frase de barba paulo
isso fala sobre a alegria das coisas que
fazem
espero que se divirtam boas aventuras
burrice
ó ó